hola a todos bienvenidos a la
transmisión en vivo del aula diaria de
khan academy y para todos aquellos que
se están preguntando qué es esto es algo
que empezamos cuando las escuelas
comenzaron a cerrar alrededor del mundo
como una manera de permanecer conectados
y tener conversaciones interesantes
acerca de cosas relacionadas con la
crisis la educación o francamente solo
conversaciones interesantes antes de
empezar con la conversación de hoy la
cual les prometo que va a ser
interesante estoy usando mucho esa
palabra quiero hacer un reconocimiento
especial a varias empresas que nos han
ayudado somos una organización sin fines
de lucro y sólo existimos gracias a
donaciones filantrópicas incluso antes
de la crisis ya trabajábamos con un
déficit y ahora el costo de nuestros
servidores ha aumentado
estamos tratando de acelerar varios
programas así que agradecemos
especialmente a bank of america
google.org haitien tim hatley y novartis
por brindarnos apoyo en tiempo récord y
ayudarnos a cerrar esta brecha
seguimos trabajando con un déficit así
que cualquier donación incluso tres o
cinco dólares se suman y eso es lo que
permite que hincan academy hagamos lo
que hacemos de manera gratuita sin fines
comerciales y accesible a estudiantes
maestros y padres de familia en todo el
mundo
dicho eso me entusiasma presentar a
nuestra invitada angelat of words angela
cómo estás
estoy bien sal y tú también estoy bien
angela tienes la distinción de ser la
primera invitada que regresa a la
transmisión en vivo
estoy muy emocionada espero no
arruinarlo eso tiene una razón no es que
lo hagamos sin pensarlo muy bien lo
tomaré como un halago jajaja es un
halago para todos aquellos que no vivan
el primer episodio en inglés con àngel
am hace unas semanas and jill am es de
hecho una autoridad mundial para hablar
acerca de la mentalidad y la
determinación y como la determinación se
relaciona con cosas como la resiliencia
y la mentalidad de crecimiento así que
pueden imaginar que en este mundo
socialmente distanciado por el kobe en
el que estamos viviendo estamos tratando
de averiguar cómo mantener motivada a la
gente como seguir aprendiendo en fin
cómo lidiar con todo lo que está
sucediendo en nuestras vidas hablar con
angela es realmente interesante y
tenemos muchas preguntas de nuestra
última sesión espero que podamos
contestar algunas de ellas pero para
todos los que están en facebook o
youtube siéntanse libres de agregar
preguntas tenemos miembros del equipo de
khan academy que nos van a pasar las
preguntas a angela ya mí
angela para empezar la vez pasada
hablamos mucho
la mentalidad de crecimiento y la
determinación y eso es fácil adentrarse
en este enfoque de que si tienes una
mentalidad de crecimiento y fallas o te
encuentras con alguna adversidad pero
simplemente sigues picando piedra
finalmente vas a salir adelante pero
como se compara eso con la otra idea de
que ya sabes no todos parten del mismo
punto no todos tienen las mismas
herramientas a su disposición entonces
por un lado está la mentalidad de
crecimiento la determinación y la
resiliencia y por otro está la equidad
en realidad si últimamente bueno no sólo
últimamente he estado leyendo críticas
acerca de mi trabajo y también el
trabajo de carol dweck sobre mentalidad
de crecimiento y cuando superó la
reacción humana natural que es de estar
a la defensiva y en realidad pongo
atención
veo que hay algo que realmente es muy
valioso y creo que la crítica es que si
hablas acerca de determinación
resiliencia mentalidad de crecimiento y
carácter suena que todo es acerca del
niño todo es acerca del estudiante
la responsabilidad recae sobre sus
hombros y no se menciona en la equidad y
la pobreza la falta de oportunidad de
saber las diferencias abismales que
todos sabemos que existen no sólo en
nuestro país sino alrededor del mundo y
creo que la conciliación es la siguiente
no es que estas ideas acerca de la
mentalidad y el aprendizaje y la
determinación stem creo en desacuerdo
con eso ya sabes no es que sea una o la
otra como si fuera o la situación o la
persona sino que son ambos brevemente te
diré que en psicología había una especie
de guerra entre los investigadores de la
psicología que pensaban que muchos de
nuestro comportamiento tiene que ver con
nuestra personalidad y con quiénes somos
luego estaban los otros psicólogos que
decían no en realidad tiene que ver con
la situación y la guerra terminó porque
en realidad todos reconocen que ambas
son importantes una vez estaba en un
salón de clase en una escuela pública
cuyo nombre no diré y había dos niños
sentados en sus escritorios y todos los
niños estaban haciendo su trabajo ya
sabes en sus computadoras portátiles
trabajando duro en alguna actividad
asignada y estos son muchachos estaban
dado sin hacer nada si hubieras entrado
al salón en ese preciso momento hubieras
dicho estos muchachos no tienen
determinación estos dos muchachos no
están haciendo nada pero yo entré al
salón justo antes de que sonara la
campana y vi cuando todos los
estudiantes iban hacia el carrito de las
computadoras y estos dos muchachos
fueron los últimos en la fila y les
tocaron dos computadoras que no servían
no pudieron hacer nada durante todo ese
tiempo porque no tuvieron la oportunidad
y creo que ese es el error que veo que
los críticos no quieren cometer no
quieren confundir falta de oportunidad
con falta de determinación y tengo que
decir que estoy completamente de acuerdo
con eso y eso es poderoso y tu ejemplo
es bueno si te toco la computadora que
no sirve digo este es un ejemplo extremo
pero es claro que ni siquiera vas a ser
capaz de aplicar tu determinación o tu
mentalidad de crecimiento y es
fascinante como muchas veces en los
círculos académicos la gente puede tomar
estas posturas dogmáticas pero
claramente no es una u otra apoyando tu
punto de que el ambiente la oportunidad
seguramente van a hacer una diferencia
pero no importa que cartas
han tocado si tienes la capacidad de
abordar la situación con una mentalidad
de crecimiento dado ese contexto vas a
llegar más lejos si todo todos los demás
permanece igual eso no quiere decir que
si dos personas no llegan a un cierto
lugar o al mismo lugar se puede culpar a
que no llegó de falta de mentalidad
puesto que podrían ser otras cosas
podría haber sido un contexto así que en
efecto para mí tiene todo el sentido del
mundo y haciendo énfasis en eso aquí hay
una pregunta de facebook
ricci hitler nos pregunta y creo que
muchos padres se están preguntando esto
muy sobre al menos uno de sus hijos como
ayudas a inspirar a un niño a querer
practicar algo es esencial que
simplemente hagamos cosas que nos guste
hacer para poder ser exitosos y tocamos
un poco este punto en nuestra última
conversación pero sí cómo motivar a
alguien para que practique algo que tal
vez no sea obvio que le encanta o
simplemente dice es bueno solo haz las
cosas que te encantan
como puedes aprender a que te gusten las
cosas
sabes desde nuestra última conversación
que fue ella hace unas semanas he estado
pensando acerca de lo que dijiste en
esta parte de la conversación dijiste
que casi cualquier cosa puede volverse
fascinante para ti y que cuando
necesitas grabar un vídeo no logra vas
hasta que estás fascinado con el tema
pero oye que puede no ser lo que podría
caer fuera de esa categoría
he estado pensando en ello porque me
pregunto si a ti siendo quién eres
esencialmente eres maestro lo que te
emociona es poder entender algo y luego
ser capaz de enseñarlo y comunicarlo me
lo puedes decir pero primero déjame
contestar directamente a esa pregunta yo
creo que cuando los niños están
empezando algo lo que hay que enfatizar
es el interés y el disfrute y si puedes
esperar un poco antes de imponer el tipo
de práctica más desafiante y repetitiva
y eso es porque antes de que un niño se
involucre de lleno en algo hay un
periodo muy romántico de hecho algunos
científicos usan el término periodo
romántico para describir ese tipo
inicial de coqueteo es como si lo que
estuvieras haciendo te produjera gozo y
después te gusta tanto
evoluciones en alguien que está
dispuesto a hacer más repeticiones y
cosas verdaderamente más difíciles ahora
con la escuela algo en lo que tú sal
tienes mucha más experiencia que yo
podría decir que por ejemplo para
matemáticas que yo sé que es donde
empezó khan academy no es necesariamente
así puede uno pensar bueno cuándo va a
llegar este periodo romántico porque por
ejemplo a mi hijo en realidad no le
gustan tanto creo que es simplemente
podrías tomar eso como un principio
cierto como cuanto gozo interés y
diversión puede haber tal vez no sea tan
divertido como minecraft pero mientras
más mejor y mientras más temprana sea la
etapa de tu desarrollo como estudiante
más vas a necesitar eso creo yo
si de la forma que yo lo veo creo que
estás en lo correcto me doy cuenta que
mi mentalidad hace a ciertas cosas tal
vez no sea tan convencional como
quisiéramos que si todos pudiéramos
quiero decir me puedo emocionar por casi
cualquier cosa por ejemplo este fin de
semana voy a limpiar la casa con una
barredoras wifi y estoy fascinado con la
idea sí cómo funciona esto me encanta mi
cantar así que tú sabes trata de
convencerme a mí mismo de que si tengo
que hacer algo bien podría disfrutarlo
puedo apreciar lo que voy a obtener de
ello y sabes un buen ejemplo es que la
mayoría de los chicos no se queja cuando
están haciendo ejercicio en el gimnasio
y ya sabes tienen que correr en la
caminadora durante 30 minutos o cuando
están intentando levantar pesas y si
están haciendo estos ejercicios bastante
extraños' para trabajar sus antebrazos o
algo así porque saben bueno por
principio de cuentas suelen disfrutarlo
porque dicen estoy haciendo algo estoy
creando un hábito esto me va a ser mejor
voy a estar mejor preparado para
enfrentarme al mundo o para entender el
mundo o para hacer
capaz de relacionarme con el mundo de
una manera más sólida así que mi
intuición es que mientras la gente
simplemente aprecie más eso más fácil
será enfrentar algunas de las cosas
difíciles con las que hay que lidiar en
la vida académica y las van a poder
superar porque van a pensar y esto me
ayuda a ser una persona más integral mi
hijo está tomando clases de piano y le
encanta tocar el piano pero es muy bien
sabido que cuando tocas el piano
tienes que practicar las escalas cierto
y son escalas al aire ya sabes para
arriba y para abajo y eso obviamente no
es componer
obviamente no vas a hacer amigos en una
fiesta con sólo tocar las escalas puede
que no sea particularmente divertido
pero cuando reconoces que al construir
esa memoria muscular y al mejorar tus
habilidades cada vez más porque incluso
los pianistas profesionales practican
las escalas las escalas realmente se
vuelven divertidas y se vuelven
interesantes y vas mejorando cada vez
que las prácticas
y creo que nos está recordando a todos
que lo interesante y divertido no es
solo objetivamente la actividad de
maestros de piano en específico conozco
a una llamada sin dylan en pasadena
california que hace que las escalas sean
divertidas hace juegos con ellas sus
estudiantes en realidad disfrutan hacer
las escalas de modo que no solamente es
que sea divertido o no sino en cierta
forma como está enmarcado sabes algo que
hace que las cosas sean realmente
aburridas para los niños es cuando no
les damos un propósito o un sentido como
hace esta hoja hace esto porque sólo
hazlo no le estamos dando al estudiante
ninguna razón para sentir que esta
actividad está conectada con un objetivo
más grande de hecho hay una ciencia del
aburrimiento y una de las razones por
las que las cosas pueden ser aburridas
es porque no tienen un propósito obvio
otra razón y de hecho acabo de escribir
sobre esto y específicamente mencioné a
khan academy como un antídoto contra
esto así que acabo de decir que una
manera de aburrirse es pensar cuál es el
objetivo de esto la otra manera de
aburrirse es cuando
cosas son demasiado fáciles o demasiado
difíciles y cualquiera de esas dos crea
la psicología del aburrimiento y la
razón por la cual mencioné khan academy
en estos pequeños ensayos es porque creo
que esta es una de las varias razones
que hacen que khan academy sea tan
genial porque permite a los estudiantes
auto calibrarse de cierta manera y
también gracias a tus algoritmos en la
plataforma se les entrega a los
estudiantes lo que necesitan en el punto
justo pero en fin como padres y como
educadores creo que el principio es
podemos hacer que las cosas sean más
disfrutables e interesantes podemos
darles a los niños un panorama más
completo como por esto es que hacemos
las lagartijas
por esta razón estamos practicando las
escalas y también lo puedes balancear de
modo que las cosas no sean demasiado
fáciles o demasiado difíciles
sí y es algo que tengo que recordarme
todo el tiempo quiero decir en especial
con he hablado de esto con otras
personas en transmisiones en vivo
nuestro hijo mayor de 11 años y el de 8
años la mayor parte del tiempo han
llevado bien este distanciamiento social
aprendiendo distancia en este mundo como
quieras llamarlo pero ha sido más
difícil para nuestro hijo de cinco años
y es muy fácil caer en esa trampa del
padre frustrado y decidir mira solo
tienes que hacer esta página am solo
tienes que hacer este ejercicio y
entonces de cierta manera se atrincheran
y después si tú y los dos van escalando
si frecuentemente hasta que en un punto
lo mandas a pensar porque ya te está
gritando ya sabes he tenido que aprender
en algunas ocasiones por el camino
difícil que hay veces que tienes que dar
un paso hacia atrás y decir a ver cómo
pongo esto en un contexto en el que en
este caso mi hijo más pequeño se
divierta cómo puedo convertir esto en un
juego porque incluso un niño de cinco
años
revelar si siente que lo están forzando
o coaccionando a diferencia de cuando le
pone empeño al proyecto incluso si ellos
no lo ven es difícil convencer a un niño
de cinco años al decirle oye al escribir
mejor vas a tener esta habilidad para
comunicarte en el mundo y vas a tener
que hacerlo por el resto de tu vida sin
embargo si solo le decimos estás
desarrollando un músculo es divertido es
un juego bueno creo que es un comienzo
de hecho algo que olvidé decir cuando te
presenté pero la gente está viendo tu
título en la pantalla es que tú
empezaste algo que se llama carácter lab
el laboratorio del carácter y muchas
personas aquí han preguntado acerca de
esto de youtube sound bomb que es
carácter la app game la pregunta para
angela nos puedes decir un poco acerca
de recursos y de carácter la app arcadia
que es carácter la app de modo que àngel
a la gente quiere saber qué es carácter
lab gracias por esas tres preguntas
porque estoy muy enamorada de carácter
lab es una organización sin fines de
lucro que comencé con los educadores
y su misión es promover conocimientos
científicos que ayuden al desarrollo de
los niños ahora carácter es una palabra
que usaron aristóteles maría montessori
y martin luther king pero creo que
comúnmente se le llama aprendizaje
socio-emocional o habilidades del siglo
21 o llámalo como quieras es la lista de
aquellas cosas que todos los padres y
educadores quieren que los niños
desarrollen gratitud y curiosidad
empatía inteligencia social
determinación mentalidad de crecimiento
hay una ciencia detrás de cualquiera de
esas cosas que mencioné y creo que en
estos tiempos emocionantes que estamos
viviendo en vez de sólo darles sermones
a nuestros niños acerca de estas cosas
que esperamos que ellos desarrollen en
realidad podemos realizar experimentos
de tareas aleatorias que muestran cómo
mejorar la mentalidad de crecimiento y
lo mismo para la gratitud etcétera así
que si vas a ese sitio web es como khan
academy apoyado por donaciones
filantrópicas de modo que si eres un
padre o un educador en particular
espero que encuentres contacto directo
con los científicos a través de este
sitio web porque cada palabra en este
sitio web ha sido escrita por un
científico no por un intermediario
y le recomiendo ampliamente nosotros en
khan academy hemos usado el trabajo de
carácter lab a veces yo lo uso como
referencia como familia y tú sabes
empezamos la school y hemos usado mucho
el trabajo de carácter lab porque una de
las cosas que tratábamos de hacer en la
school es que los niños no solo se
desarrollen académicamente sino que el
desarrollo socioemocional es una parte
muy explícita ya hemos usado muchas de
las taxonomías y marcos de referencia de
carácter la fap para pensar acerca de
cómo le hacemos para saber qué elementos
importan y cómo lo hacemos para medir o
pensar en medir algunas de estas cosas
bueno de youtube aquí tenemos a un
profesor daniel que un roe se pregunta
cómo pueden los profesores fomentar la
determinación durante el aprendizaje a
distancia con los estudiantes fuera de
nuestro alcance parece ser más fácil que
nunca para ellos darse por vencidos
esta es una pregunta que siento muy
cercana tengo hijos de 18 y 17 años en
la casa un poquito más adelante de ti en
términos de las edades de mis hijos y
cuando no sólo está el aprendizaje a
distancia sino que también existe esta
línea borrosa entre la mañana a la tarde
y la noche entre día laborable y fin de
semana simplemente es muy fácil que
repentinamente hayan pasado nueve días y
no hayamos hecho nada en realidad de
modo que es una pregunta estupenda creo
que la persona a quien más se ha
consultado por su sabiduría durante este
periodo de aprendizaje a distancia ha
sido romper gere ya sabes las escuelas
de aprendizaje expedicionario y ron en
particular como director académico es un
sabio en estas cosas y creo que su
consejo sería tomar la oportunidad del
aprendizaje a distancia y esta extrañeza
forzada que tenemos como educadores para
movernos de manera más agresiva hacia el
aprendizaje basado en proyectos sabes
hacia cosas que no sólo son hace esta
hoja llena esto es más como tener un
proyecto como en el que vamos a tratar
de averiguar cómo hacer trabajo de
reciclaje en este vecindario
podrías hacer algo que sea muy
específico en términos de comida como
por ejemplo hay mucha gente mayor en
nuestro vecindario cómo podemos abordar
esto como un proyecto por ejemplo y por
sus víveres ahora tal vez estés pensando
que estas cosas que tienen que ver o
cómo se relacionan con leer escribir y
con aritmética y creo que ahí no siempre
es fácil encontrar la relación pero ese
es el reto en otras palabras cuando
haces proyectos que son auténticos
si tienes que hacer un poco más de
trabajo como educador en pensar cómo vas
a integrar algunas de las habilidades
básicas que los estudiantes necesitan
aprender pero creo que esta tendencia es
realmente poderosa porque cuando tienes
un proyecto que te emociona no tienes
que sufrir para hacerlo te emociona
hacerlo y francamente estás pensando en
ello todo el tiempo para aprender más
sobre esto si buscas en google
aprendizaje expedicionario y rome berger
vas a encontrar que está escribiendo
muchas cosas acertadas ahora mismo
y aquí tocas un tema interesante hemos
hablado acerca de este tipo de posturas
estas posturas dogmáticas que a veces se
toman en los círculos académicos de los
que hablábamos antes y tiene que ver con
el contexto y la equidad o más bien con
la mentalidad y tu punto es que no es
uno o el otro sino que importan ambos y
sabes he visto algo parecido porque
estábamos hablando acerca del
aprendizaje basado en proyectos
he visto una batalla dogmática parecida
en los círculos educativos en donde está
ahí creo que podremos decir los
tradicionalistas que dirían no tienes
que aprender esas habilidades tienes que
aprender y practicar las escalas por
decirlo de alguna manera antes de
convertirse en un gran pianista y
también tenemos los que podríamos llamar
educadores progresistas con un programa
basado en proyectos quienes dicen no
tienes que empezar a componer desde el
primer día así que se vuelve interesante
pero lo que te escuché decir es que
sigue siendo un poco de ambos es decir
no es todo o nada
un lado o el otro
sí absolutamente sabes ambos extremos
son en realidad la respuesta a muchas
preguntas y creo que es porque se
compensa en cierto en el aprendizaje
basado en proyectos obtiene ciertas
ventajas pero tal vez no obtengas la
parte densamente compacta de habilidades
repetitivas cierto pero cuando haces
solo esto último entonces tal vez
pierdas un poco de la motivación
intrínseca y el propósito y justo
estábamos hablando acerca de que eso
puede ser realmente desmotivante así que
creo que el aprendizaje basado en
proyectos y tal vez una instrucción un
poco más tradicional quiero decir no soy
una experta o una educadora veterana
pero me parece que son complementarios y
cuando te fijas en las mejores escuelas
y los mejores salones de clase
simplemente los mejores ambientes de
aprendizaje de manera general tienden a
tener tanto rigor como autonomía tienden
a tener proyectos creativos y un enfoque
sistemático y esto es porque de nuevo no
es fácil hacerlo pero sí creo que es a
lo que le estamos apuntando
si completamente de acuerdo sabes usando
una analogía de deportes si eres un
jugador de fútbol obviamente tienes que
practicar jugar fútbol es decir tienes
que jugar partidos que sean como
partidos reales y esos son como los
proyectos pero también tienes que correr
y levantar pesas y ejercicios de lanzar
y atrapar el balón ya sabes simplemente
diferentes ejercicios aleatorios que se
sienten un poco y vas a perfeccionar
esos ejercicios y de nuevo si solo
hicieras estos ejercicios te sentirías
como cuál es el objetivo pero cuando
sabes que esto te está preparando más
para un partido y puede que uses o no
algunas de estas habilidades en un
cierto partido pero es un conjunto de
herramientas útil para el resto de tu
vida entonces de repente eso también
puede ser motivante y eso es lo que les
digo a los niños mira no estoy seguro
que vas a tener que usar este método
para factorizar una función cuadrática
en algún momento en los próximos cinco
años realmente no estoy seguro pero si
estoy seguro de que
al entender esto vas a poder construir
sobre eso de modo que puedes aprender
cosas como estadística puedes aprender
cosas como trigonometría y no te puedo
decidir en cuántas áreas
quiero decir solo estadística si estás
hablando de un proyecto casi cualquier
proyecto si quieres hacerlo de manera
legítima con un cierto nivel de impacto
en el mundo vas a tener que usar
estadística diseñando o creando vas a
tener que usar algo de trigonometría
geometría y de algo de álgebra básica
cualquier cosa que hagas en este mundo
ser capaz de tener una comprensión de
lectura razonable de habilidades de
escritura va a ser lo que inclina la
balanza en este mundo así que es bueno
asegurarse que no tengas ese error de
ortografía que se puede notar y que
digan vaya crisis tú no sabe escribir lo
que a mí me pasa a veces y siempre le
echo la culpa a los errores tipográficos
pero hasta porque escribo demasiado
rápido para tener una conversación mira
a veces la gente me pregunta cosas como
cuántos años necesitan tener tus hijos
antes de que les puedas hablar a un
nivel
explicación acerca de algunos de estos
temas como la metacognición está
demasiado alejada de ellos como para que
realmente puedan entender por qué están
haciendo esto porque no estoy haciendo
yo y yo digo honestamente que nunca se
es demasiado joven simplemente empieza
quiero decir los niños son más listos
que nosotros así que adelante no uses
jerga técnica si no lo entienden intenta
explicarlo de otra manera pero creo que
uno de los grandes cambios en la
educación me pregunto si estás de
acuerdo o sal bueno espero que sea un
cambio en la educación y no quiero decir
que el estudiante y el profesor sean
intercambiables y que no hay ninguna
razón por la cual tendríamos que hacerlo
así no estoy diciendo eso lo único que
quiero decir es que los estudiantes son
notablemente perceptivos e inteligentes
y que pueden entender cuando les dices
algo como esa es la razón por la cual
estamos haciendo esto como cuando les
dices el alcance y las secuencias son
estos y pues tenemos que pasar por esta
parte para poder llegar a esta otra pero
si no llegas a esta parte
sabes así que no creo que sean demasiado
jóvenes para entender todas esas cosas y
nunca deberíamos suponer que son
demasiado jóvenes para entender esas
cosas siempre deberíamos por lo menos
intentar comunicarles el porqué de lo
que están haciendo
estoy 100% de acuerdo creo que es fácil
para nosotros suponer que a los 5 o 6 7
u 8 años no piensan acerca de cómo
funciona el mundo pero si lo hacen y si
les hablas acerca de los trabajos y del
lugar del trabajo competitivo y cómo y
qué habilidades necesitas para poder
participar es gracioso
creo que esto sucedió hace muchos años
ha de haber sido hace unos cinco o seis
años recibí un correo electrónico de una
madre que tenía una foto de su hijo en
donde estaba trabajando con diligencia
era un niño de siete años y me sentí mal
en fin
sucede que hice una entrevista como esta
en la cual estaba hablando acerca del
futuro del trabajo y de que el futuro
del trabajo va a estar definido por
nuestra habilidad de seguir aprendiendo
de que no solo vas a tener un conjunto
de habilidades que vas a utilizar hasta
que obtengas tu pensión la
automatización e incluso un poco de van
a ser la mano de obra inteligencia
artificial cierto inteligencia
artificial robótica de modo que querrás
poder estar en la punta de la pirámide
de la economía del conocimiento y poner
tanta gente como puedas
y creo que esta madre vio esa entrevista
con su hijo de siete años y luego
inmediatamente después de la entrevista
él fue a su cuarto y ella no lo vio como
por una hora cuando ella fue a perdón le
pregunto qué estás haciendo y él
respondió estoy trabajando en khan
academy y ella le preguntó por qué y él
les dijo necesito asegurarme de no ser
marginado económicamente
y de hecho creo que usó palabras como
marginado económicamente claramente era
un niño precoz y usaba palabras como
ésas a los 7 años pero si dijo algo que
se sintió como quiero estar seguro de
que la automatización no me deje fuera
de la economía así que él
definitivamente entendió y eso recuerdo
recuerdo que hay una cita estoy viendo a
mí mismo hay una cita app de karma long
un famoso basquetbolista del iut alias
él solía decir cada vez que estoy
cansado imagino que mis competidores
están en el gimnasio
no quiero que con eso las personas se
estresen porque siempre hay que estar en
la cima pero eso también puede ser un
pequeño motivador ya sabes no quieres
que tus hijos se estresen pero tampoco
quieres que vivan en una realidad en la
que crean que chávez en realidad yo veo
esto como el ímpetu yo crecí sin mucho
dinero de modo que tenía algo de ímpetu
arrollador que decía quiero un nivel de
vida diferente no lo sabía o si mi mamá
ahm bueno mi mamá ella no escribo sola
era cajera de algunas tiendas de
conveniencia y el año en el que envié mi
solicitud a la universidad
ella estaba ganando 16 mil dólares al
año por eso para mí creo un poco de ese
ímpetu arrollador porque veía a mis
amigos cuyos padres eran médicos
ingenieros y abogados y yo pensaba esa
es una buena vida viven en una casa
bonita se pueden ir de vacaciones van a
restaurantes no tienen que reutilizar
las toallas de papel esa es la vida que
quiero todavía reutilizó las toallas de
papel de vez en cuando pero esa es la
vida que quiero pero a veces nos
preocupamos porque los niños
en la clase media o incluso en la clase
media-alta dicen como mis papás hicieron
esto debe ser fácil así son las cosas
pero después les toca un despertar rudo
al darse cuenta de que el mundo a veces
puede ser un poco ya sabes que estos
trabajos no te caen del cielo que
necesitas prepararte para ellos y hay
niños con este ímpetu arrollador que se
están preparando desde muy jóvenes
porque ven la razón para ello desde una
corta edad dicen vaya si continúo en
este camino con mis estudios y terminó
la preparatoria y me va bien en la
universidad podré vivir ahí y podré irme
de vacaciones y apoyar a mi familia y si
no puede que viva bajo estrés financiero
por un tiempo muy muy muy largo y sabes
con respecto a tu punto anterior sobre
equidad no tiene que ver con la
mentalidad del niño con seguridad tiene
que ver mucho con el apoyo por ejemplo
aunque yo no crecí con muchas
comodidades tuve mucho apoyo tenía apoyo
de los profesores que creyeron en mí y
que ellas me pusieron más atención
yo estaba expuesto a personas que lo
lograron
de esa manera de modo que incluso pude
ver ese lado del mundo pero si es
fascinante cómo podemos mantener esa
motivación al hacerle saber a la gente
un poco acerca de la realidad del mundo
pero sin expresarlos demasiado
absolutamente juzga lotus pero creo que
una de las cosas que estás diciendo y
con lo que estoy de acuerdo es que los
niños no necesitan estar tan protegidos
por ejemplo mi papá no era tan bueno en
pensar en cómo hablar con los niños ver
simplemente me hablaba como si yo fuera
un adulto y no siempre era bueno pero en
su mayoría sí estuvo bien de modo que
aprendí acerca de la oferta y la demanda
y aprendí sobre su punto de vista
particular de la economía y aprendí
sobre termodinámica y en fin creo que
los niños son mucho más inteligentes y
están mucho más preparados de lo que les
damos crédito y si lo intentamos podemos
tener conversaciones con ellos acerca de
por ejemplo que significa ser marginado
en la economía del conocimiento y tal
vez podamos encontrar palabras que sean
un poco más intuitivas para ellos pero
eso no significa que no debamos intentar
tener esas conversaciones
creo que soy como tú papá soy culpable
de que a todos mis hijos todas las
canciones de cuna que les canto son
canciones de rock clásicas de las que
tengo la letra de modo que para mis
hijos su canción de cuna para la noche
de hecho anoche con la soft que tiene
cinco años y medio de edad cantamos
hotel california
y él preguntaba qué significa que su
mente está retorcida x un mercedes
piensa la paja que es colita así porque
tiene un aroma tibio y así por cierto a
mí me puedes explicar hotel california y
entonces tal vez podría escuchar porque
obviamente no seres es una canción
profunda literal o es metafórica puedes
registrar tu salida cuando quieras pero
nunca puede decirte exactamente eso ha
conducido a muchas conversaciones con
mis hijos qué quiere decir registrar tu
ser hoy de 'la pero no me llegas a tener
una explicación breve un análisis de un
deal california la voy a agradecer
porque por ahora sigo un poco si hay
veces en las que tengo que cuando mi
hijo de 5 años se pregunta por qué la
pone hablan con sus
chicos de acero y que se están tratando
de matar yo digo ok aquí hay que
detenernos bien es hora de dormir no
vamos a hacer esto ahora a la cama
porque no te has dormido
bueno aquí hay una buena pregunta desde
facebook antes de que la gente empieza a
notar más horribles hábitos de crianza
así que de steven contra él cuáles son
algunos consejos para desarrollar un
sentido de propósito en los adolescentes
muy buena pregunta bueno uno de los
datos menos conocidos pero creo que es
más importante acerca de los
adolescentes es que ellos tal vez estén
más impulsados por propósitos durante
ese periodo de la vida que en cualquier
otro y tenemos un estereotipo de los
adolescentes como egoístas e incluso
narcisistas y en realidad al contrario
están extremadamente motivados por la
justicia la equidad y por el cambio
social
yo esto lo vivo con mis hijos de 17 y de
18 años a menudo hago mini lecciones
acerca de que me considero alguien que
es razonablemente feminista y ellos me
actualizan y me corrigen cuando creen
que es necesario entonces la pregunta es
cómo canalizamos toda esta motivación
impulsada por los adolescentes y creo
que un desafío verdadero en particular
durante este verano es que muchas de las
cosas que normalmente sugeriría como ser
voluntario en esto o hacer aquello están
excluidas así que este verano va a
requerir un poco más de creatividad y
proactividad para canalizar de manera
apropiada el propósito de los
adolescentes algo que acabo de escuchar
es que ahora hay y te voy a enviar los
vínculos al no es perfecto pero
honestamente creo que es genial hay
maneras para que los adolescentes sean
tutores de niños más jóvenes durante
todo el verano y como tú bien sabes al
la pandemia no sólo ha evidenciado la
falta de equidad sino que también ha
aumentado la falta de equidad y creo que
hay muchas personas incluyendo nos
attiyah min
quienes estamos aterrados ante las
pérdidas de aprendizaje
en particular para los niños menos
favorecidos de modo que si tienes un
adolescente motivado en casa voy a
enviar vínculos con formas en las que
ellos podrían insertarse como tutores y
uno de los aspectos positivos es que no
importa en donde vivas puedes encontrar
un niño que esté en tu zona horaria y ya
sabes la teoría de la estrella de mar
cierto prevenir que por lo menos un niño
se atrase este año
si simplemente voy a subrayar lo que
acaba de decir para cualquier
adolescente o joven o persona que diga
qué hago conmigo mismo ahora nunca ha
habido por lo menos en nuestras vidas
mayor oportunidad allá afuera incluso
una persona joven desde su habitación en
realidad puede hacer mucho bien al mundo
para seguir con tu punto podría ser
tutor de otras personas podrás crear una
nueva organización que conecte tal vez a
los adultos mayores que están viviendo
solos o simplemente gente que está
viviendo sola o ayudar en temas de salud
mental y todas estas cosas están
dispuestas para poder hacerse de manera
remota y si necesitas salir de casa
puedes ir por víveres para alguien en
especial para gente mayor puedes
ayudarlos con algunos servicios
tú puedes cualquier adolescente
cualquier persona joven allá afuera si
tienes una lluvia de ideas de media hora
vas a pensar en 30 maneras realmente
fascinantes en las que puedes realmente
ayudar a mucha gente ahora mismo así que
he escuchado que hay adolescentes que
están anotando su número de celular en
un pedazo de papel y luego solo lo meten
a los buzones
y como te podrás imaginar no a todos los
adultos mayores les gusta mandar
mensajes de texto o alguna otra cosa así
que con sólo decir llámame llámame aquí
es donde vivo
me encantaría recoger tus víveres o ir a
la farmacia por ti sí como dijiste sal
cuando simplemente te sientas y empiezas
a hacer una lista te das cuenta de que
hay mucho que hacer y en realidad creo
que es en esos momentos cuando los
adolescentes están más contentos cuando
están siendo útiles y es de nuevo el
antídoto para el tipo de desesperación
que creo que muchos de los adolescentes
están sintiendo una falta de objetivos y
el sentimiento de que me quitaron todas
estas cosas pero cuando empiezas a salir
y a pasar la mayor parte de tu día
ayudando a otras personas todo eso
básicamente se evapora sí creo que aquí
hay otro tema que es que está este tipo
de ansiedad adolescente y que están en
plena reversión y creo que eso viene del
hecho de que son pronto adultos que
durante la mayor parte de la historia
humana en realidad estarían en los
grupos de casa estarían ayudando con
todas las cosas que se necesitan hacer
en la aldea y la cocina y la limpieza
a la cacería las peleas lo que fuera
pero nuestra sociedad moderna y esto lo
haríamos en grupos con gente de todas
las edades ellos estarían con tíos
confirmó sí con tías pero ahora los
agrupamos en estas franjas de edad
bastante angostas y les decimos que sólo
deben preocuparse por ellos mismos eso
es raro no se te hace extraño tu
promedio tus calificaciones
tu admisión a la universidad tus
actividades extracurriculares de ahí es
de donde viene la ansiedad para
clasificarte exactamente te vamos a
clasificar si es tan raro es decir
durante la mayor parte de la historia
humana es exactamente como lo dices la
gente la gente incluido los niños iban
de un lado a otro en grupos de varias
edades los de cinco años con los de
siete los de siete con los de doce y por
cierto cuando ves niños de 5 7 y 12
espontáneamente ves o de manera
espontánea ves colaboración que los de
12 años cuidan a los de 7 los de 7
cuidan a los de 5
ahora estamos en esta era realmente rara
en la que tomamos unos mil chicos de 15
años y los ponemos juntos para que pasen
juntos todo el tiempo
y después nos vamos a clasificar no es
cierto de modo que sólo están
compitiendo entre ellos y no tienen una
responsabilidad tangible más que estas
cosas abstractas creo que tienes que
aprender todo esto obviamente soy un
gran creyente
tienes que aprender biología química o
escáner matemáticas o no pero todo es
abstracto y solo se trata de tu propio
desempeño en esas cosas no se trata de
algo colectivo no se trata de hacerlos y
retomando tu punto ellos son más
idealistas es decir parte de la razón
por la cual muchos soldados y demás son
más bien jóvenes
obviamente tu cuerpo es muy capaz
físicamente en esta etapa pero estas son
algunas de las personas más idealistas y
ya lo sabes en la historia
así es algunas veces ha habido personas
que han tomado ventaja no en el buen
sentido de esa situación pero ellos
creen que puede haber un cambio y
quieren aventurarse al mundo no quieren
caer directo en la rutina del día a día
así que si estoy 100% de acuerdo contigo
bueno cada vez que platicamos angela el
tiempo pasa muy muy rápido bueno yo creo
que sí
tenemos tiempo para una más una más una
más y si tienes tiempo para una más y
tengo tiempo para una más de acuerdo
suena bien veamos déjame encontraste una
buena todas son tan geniales de modo que
esto es difícil vamos a cerrar con
broche de oro por acá tenemos veamos
qué bueno que tú estés escogiendo
bueno pues hay un par de preguntas por
aquí sabes que voy a agrupar estás muy
bien karli instrument dice cuál crees
que sea la mejor manera de enseñarle a
los niños a dividir sus propias tareas
grandes y por extensión a todos nosotros
a dividirlas estamos hablando de un
problema grande quieres resolver la
soledad como lo resuelves o lo que
decíamos hace rato y bueno de youtube a
drew o mauri hay algunas estrategias que
puedan recomendar para concentrarte y
ser productivo y después
brady y me preguntan cómo puedes
conectar la falta de motivación hacia el
aprendizaje en línea con quedarse en
casa me dado cuenta que a muchos les
cuesta trabajo concentrarse así que si
tienes algunos pensamientos para cerrar
sobre cómo dividir las cosas permanecer
motivados
concentrarse en estar enfocado bueno
solamente voy a dar una sugerencia y es
que esta intuición que tienes de que
algo grande se tiene que dividir en
cosas más pequeñas es precisamente
correcta y de hecho hubo una
investigación realizada no muy lejos de
donde salgan vive por albán dura en la
universidad de stanford
hace ya muchos años en la que tenía
niños de primaria que estaban
aprendiendo matemáticas y en una
situación tenían que aprender muchas
matemáticas y en otra situación lo que
él hizo fue ayudar a dividir las
matemáticas las mismas matemáticas en
objetivos secundarios empates más
pequeñas y hubo un beneficio dramático y
a esos niños les fue mejor y creo que la
lección de vida como dices al no sólo
para los niños sino para nosotros es que
cuando tienes cosas grandes que hacer
las divides en cosas más pequeñas y
cuando tomas esas cosas pequeñas y las
divides aún más
ahí es cuando creo que en realidad
obtienes impulso y voy a dar un ejemplo
personal lo más difícil que he hecho de
manera profesional fue escribir mi libro
y cuando pensaba en escribir un libro
era algo demasiado grande después pensé
bueno solo voy a trabajar en el capítulo
1 seguía siendo demasiado grande después
pensé bueno solo voy a trabajar en la
primera mitad del capítulo 1 seguía
siendo demasiado grande y me di cuenta
que estaba procrastinar y que nunca me
sentía con ganas de empezar y por fin lo
dividía en lo más pequeño que pude y
decía hoy tal vez voy a escribir un
enunciado
y lo que quería decir con tal vez es que
quizá eliminaría ese enunciado y
entonces dividí lo grande un libro en
cosas más pequeñas un capítulo en cosas
más pequeñas de modo que lo que tenía
que hacer ese día era muy poco y en
realidad creo que esa fue una muy buena
estrategia porque una vez que escribí
ese enunciado pensé bueno ya que estoy
aquí sentada de una vez puedo escribir
otro y en general creo que si podemos
ayudar a los niños a aprender la
habilidad de dividir las cosas grandes
en cosas más pequeñas y empezar entonces
en realidad nos estaremos encaminando a
ayudarlos a terminar lo que empiecen
si no puedo estar más de acuerdo tú
sabes esa es la gran parte de mi
narrativa también estas tareas que
puedes trabajar media hora con una hora
de picar piedra y cuando miras hacia
atrás te das cuenta de que era bastante
si se suman es mejor que nada que es
básicamente lo que sucede cuando
procrastinar entonces no estás haciendo
nada cierto sólo empiezan solo empieza
así que angela muchas gracias
quiero decir siguen llegando muchas
preguntas muy buenas pero sin gracias
por toda la investigación que has hecho
y por ayudarnos a pensar en cómo podemos
tener más determinación y en cómo
podemos trabajar con nuestros hijos para
poner eso en marcha gracias a ti tan
disfruté mucho esta conversación
igualmente
gracias a todos por unirse como siempre
angelat of words es informativa y
entretenida y siempre es un placer
platicar con ella acerca de todos los
temas y tenemos varios personajes
realmente interesantes que estarán con
nosotros vamos a tener a don fridman
esta semana hablando del mundo y de este
mundo del cómic vamos a tener a estos
miles de admisiones del instituto
tecnológico de massachusetts y my team
para hablar acerca de como el ingreso a
la universidad y simplemente la
naturaleza de la universidad podrían
cambiar debido a esta crisis y tenemos
muchos muchos más invitados a lo largo
de las siguientes semanas así que espero
verlos a todos y no olviden que somos
una organización sin fines de lucro y
que si tienes la posibilidad de hacerlo
por favor considera hacer una donación a
khan academy gracias a todos